everything is racist
everything is racist
is it racist to want more sun when times
the same for everyone
CNN suggests daylight savings time might
as well be a hate crime it has a new CNN
online article titled Daylight Saving
Time sheds light on lack of sleeps
disproportionate impact in communities
of color
and if you're having trouble sleeping
try reading that article yes the piece
explains that daylight savings time can
cause sleep issues and sleep issues can
cause health problems and since
minorities have more health problems all
the clock switching must be hurting them
more than it hurts white people
but that's a bigger reach than Dana
Perino opening a car door
[Laughter]
can always mean causation dog owners
tend to be healthier not because of the
dog but because of all the walking and
that's why I got a dog my assistant is
so much healthier
and I don't provide insurance
well I got some Applause
but obviously that killed the joke if
you argue from the insanely broad
conclusion that minorities have more
health problems due to racism you could
then say everything is racist example
Brian Kilmeade has a radio show in
America minorities have more health
problems in America which makes it
harder for them to access radio shows in
some Brian Kilmeade is a racist
I don't have any proof of that I just
want his show canceled
cat
I used to be totally against daylight
savings time now I love it because I
realized I was always I Had It reversed
like without daylight savings times it's
dark earlier yeah but if you had more
debt we should be amping it up like do
it like three hours and make it
permanent who cares if it's dark in the
morning nothing fun happens in the
morning nothing fun happens in the
morning
[Applause]
yeah because when are you waking up in
the morning like I'm so glad that
sunlight's so bright yeah nobody says
that unless you're sicko no if you're
like some kind of weird vampire yeah
like you're like a reverse vampire like
a sicko and like you go for a run before
work oh yeah you have to tell everybody
Loser yeah uh no it's the worst it's so
sad it's dark out at like four o'clock
and in the winter where it's like
already hard to find a will to live yes
you're just like on the cusp of a mentee
bee at all times and now you can it's
dark outside which it shouldn't match
your insides I like to when you walk
those nice two minutes you get from the
office to the car and then home to the
car those nice two minutes outside to
see the sun yes I missed those four
cumulative minutes of outdoor Sunshine
yes it means everything to me does that
make us racist Nick yeah a little bit oh
okay explain yeah a little bit I had to
sit there and listen to that junk yeah I
love the morning I love the sun on my
face when I get up early
I uh but
I'm playing this game wrong yes instead
of fighting this ignorant stupid about
how somehow my blackness prevents me
from getting up or being on time for
work and I can only work in non-daylight
savings I'm just going to agree with it
yeah so I'll see you all in June
and uh I will be 20 to 15 minutes late
because
I'm gonna do a minority so
oh sun's out getting sick gotta go
that is true it's a very racist article
in the article the one of the experts
mentioned the death of Brianna Taylor
who was killed uh uh a little bit before
George Floyd while sleeping because of a
no knock raid that was issued she was
black she's an EMT she was shot to death
in her bed by drug cops executing a fake
warrant as part of the drug war the drug
war is racist daylight savings time not
something but this this is something
oh my goodness they mentioned the
bullets it was the later son she was
asleep and you know we need to research
that to see if there's a connection
there it's sickening because there are
real problems that we can deal with yeah
and then there's BS like daylight
savings time I will say this though you
know Mercedes it's this kind of crazy
topic that makes it on this show I know
so I'm grateful when these topics come
up but you know in the footnote of the
study it said that this show is racist
it's the weirdest thing because you're
so late at 11 o'clock see people have to
stay up they're getting not getting
enough sleep I mean things have to
change Greg I don't know what you're
doing making you stay up late so be fair
to Greg the show actually is supposed to
be filmed it started at 8pm but I don't
get here till 11.
he wants to confront me and he does
sometimes and I just go
the mother of five kids where I didn't
sleep for a decade I didn't sleep for a
decade at night okay for the those new
mothers that's the real problem because
they don't sleep so I think that's the
study they should do instead of
creating this can't you just blindfold
your kids
you
gotta handcuff them they'll just get out
of it oh
you have to put earmuffs so you don't
hear the crime it's a lot of work
yes
[Laughter]
with a straw it's for the air hey my
parents did that to me and I turned out
okay great hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else